[Música]
bueno
las emociones han existido siempre
en todos los lugares y en todas las
épocas el ser humano ha tendido a
interpretar sus experiencias según lo
que sentía pero no siempre hemos sentido
lo mismo y tampoco siempre lo hemos
llamado con las mismas palabras
yo llevo 20 años trabajando sobre la
historia de las emociones una disciplina
relativamente nueva desde la que
intentamos replantearnos lo que son las
emociones y evitar las versiones
simplificadas y partimos de tres
premisas la primera es que las emociones
no son sólo la cara que ponemos al
expresarlas como parece que piensan paul
ekman y sus seguidores en eeuu la
segunda es que las emociones las vivimos
a través del lenguaje que los nombres
que les damos y las palabras con que las
expresamos son esenciales para
entenderlas y la tercera es que esas
palabras tienen una larga historia a la
que han ido cambiando de significado
voy a ilustrar tres aspectos de mi
trabajo sobre las emociones con ejemplos
extraídos de documentos históricos el
primer aspecto es el poder de la
imaginación sobre las emociones la
imaginación con solo
que pensemos en algo que podría ocurrir
ya nos hace sentir emociones y propongo
que ejercitamos nuestra empatía para
pasar a momentos históricos empezando
con principios del siglo xv en el
momento en que los navegadores
portugueses
partían con miedo intentando bordear la
costa de áfrica y sin saber si iban a
conseguir llegar más allá que sus
predecesores y sin saber si iban a poder
regresar y lo que les llevaba a superar
el miedo y embarcarse era la esperanza
la esperanza de conseguir beneficios
económicos bien en aquel momento de
ausencias el rey don duarte de portugal
escribió sobre lo que entonces se
denominaba sociedades las sociedades en
la definía como algo que sentimos con el
corazón en dos tipos de situación una es
al estar alejados de la persona a quien
tenemos gran afecto y la otra ya antes
de que eso ocurra cuando sabemos que esa
separación es inminente
el rey también distinguía entre la
saudade que sentimos como recuerdo de un
pasado que disfrutamos mucho y la que
sentimos simplemente al pensar en lo que
nos gustaría que ocurriera
pues esta última idea es bastante
parecida algo podríamos llamar falsa
nostalgia que a veces nos creamos a
nosotros mismos soñando despiertos el
rey también hizo una distinción entre la
saudade triste y la saudade placentera
la triste es cuando el recuerdo nos hace
desear ansiosamente echar marcha atrás y
estar en aquella conversación con ese
amigo que ahora ya no está y la
placentera es cuando en lugar de sufrir
por esa ausencia disfrutamos los
recuerdos del tiempo pasado
bueno pues pasamos ahora a otro momento
histórico finales del siglo 17 el
momento que se inventa la palabra
nostalgia era mil 688 y un suizo que
estudiaba medicina en la universidad de
basilea llamado johannes hoffa hizo su
tesis sobre un fenómeno que observó
entre gente que vivía alejada de su país
algunos el estar lejos de su tierra les
hacía entristecerse y languidecían y
enfermaban y no se recuperaban este
fenómeno ya tenía nombre en alemán se
llamaba jaime y en francés se llamaba
maddy pace lo que ocurre es que estos
términos no resultaban convincentes como
categoría nosológica para hacer
diagnósticos se necesitaba un término
técnico y entonces el joven se le
ocurrió combinar dos palabras griegas
los dos que significa vuelta a casa y
algia de algo que significa dolor entre
los casos que incluyó hoffer en su tesis
encontramos a un suizo que emigró a
parís
una vez allí echaba tanto de menos las
montañas suizas que enfermo al querer
verlas otra vez y no podrá hacerlo
entonces el momento en que el señor para
que el que trabajaba le concedió permiso
para viajar empezó a recuperarse se
recuperó del todo y al final ni viajo y
lo cuento como ejemplo de como el pensar
que algo es posible ya nos hace cambiar
la forma de sentir y también para que
nos planteemos si en nuestra cultura
valoramos lo suficiente el poder de la
imaginación además este ejemplo me lleva
al segundo aspecto que quiero dar a
conocer con mi trabajo sobre las
emociones y es que la relación de mente
cuerpo y emociones que se entendió desde
la medicina hipocrática desde hace 25
siglos y se empezó a olvidar como a
mediados del siglo 19 y está empezando a
recordarse es algo que está ahí y las
emociones
influyen sobre nuestra salud física y
mental y lo que hacemos con el cuerpo lo
que dormimos lo que comemos y cuánto y
si hacemos mucho ejercicio llevamos una
vida muy sedentaria tiene un claro
efecto sobre lo que sentimos
vamos a verlo también en el contexto de
1.792 habían pasado tres años desde la
revolución francesa y se iniciaba una
guerra que duraría 23 años las guerras
revolucionarias y napoleónicas durante
ese momento de la historia de francia
la nostalgia se convirtió en algo
epidémico fue la mayor causa de
suicidios y se escribieron numerosos
tratados
y artículos sobre el tema y habiendo
leído unos cuantos voy a
descifrar lo que son me parece a mí que
son cuatro factores uno es que muchos de
los soldados que aparecían en los
hospitales en estado nostálgico muy
enfermos habían sufrido heridas y
estaban débiles y mal nutridos y esa
debilidad les hacía sentirse tristes y
querer volver a casa el otro factor es
que muchos de ellos luchaban obligados
por unos ideales en los que a veces ni
siquiera creían era una nación francesa
nueva una república que a veces no
entendían el tercer factor es que en
aquel momento de la historia de francia
un tercio de la población francesa no
hablaba francés como lengua madre
hablaba apretón alemán vasco o catalán y
entonces el hecho de que muchos esos
soldados hablaran dialectos o lenguas
que otros no hablaban contribuye a lo
que yo veo como cuarto factor el
aislamiento la soledad y la
incomunicación voy a dar un ejemplo que
explica un poco estos factores en 1692
un cirujano llamado mo goteras acta curo
a un soldado nostálgico simplemente
pidiendo a otro soldado de su región que
tuviera conversaciones con él en las que
fueran rememorando vivencias de su
pasado y con esto consiguió curarle en
el soldado recuperó las ganas de vivir
de seguir luchando y parece ser que el
salir de la soledad con las
conversaciones y con las rememoraciones
de sus vivencias del pasado fue la mejor
terapia no todos los médicos pensaban
que la nostalgia era una enfermedad
aparte muchos pensaban que era
simplemente un tipo de melancolía y la
melancolía desde antiguo se entendía
como algo que afectaba a la mente y al
cuerpo y que estaba asociado con el
miedo y la tristeza
bueno pues desde finales la primera
guerra mundial ya nadie se ha muerto ni
de nostalgia ni de melancolía estos
términos han cambiado de significado y
como vemos algunas emociones similares
tienen nombres y matices distintos según
su relación con el tiempo y con el
espacio en cada época y lugar conforme
cambian las circunstancias y las
sensibilidades se han encontrado
síntomas diferentes asociados a
emociones y se han encontrado también en
formas de manejar las terapias
diferentes por ejemplo la nostalgia
antigua la saudade tienen en común la
sensación de soledad y estas dos tienen
en común con la melancolía el
sentimiento de ausencia que a veces
lleva a el ensimismamiento la melancolía
ya empezó a cambiar a manos del
psicoanálisis cuando le dieron un
significado muy parecido lo que hoy
entendemos como depresión en 1917
freud escribió y publicó un tratado
sobre una medicación a distinción entre
el duelo como tristeza ante una pérdida
de algo o alguien importante y la
melancolía como una tristeza de más
larga duración que no tenía causas
evidentes
siete décadas más tarde la psicoanalista
lingüista julia kristeva retomó esa
distinción y añadió que a veces ante
situaciones de pérdida real o sentida
nos aferramos a la tristeza como si ésta
pudiera suplir aquello que sentimos que
hemos perdido y además ella sugería una
alternativa al uso de fármacos
antidepresivos el conectar con imágenes
artísticas y con poemas según kristeva
y aquellos que tienen demasiada tristeza
son incapaces de encontrar el sentido al
lenguaje lógico y sin embargo el
lenguaje poético con sus ritmos
aliteraciones y rimas puede hacer
enganchar que está triste y hacerle
procesar y superar o transformar esa
tristeza
desde mi punto de vista el escuchar
música o el escuchar
y poemas en lenguaje poético y sus
ritmos nos pueden ayudar a entender que
las emociones no es algo que llevamos
dentro y que expresamos sino algo que
nos ayuda a conectar con otros y
propongo un experimento
escuchemos parte de un poema de rosalía
de castro de 1884 en el que
se alude a la saudade de la mujer del
emigrante que está a punto de partir y
también se evocan otras emociones que
ayudan a contrarrestar esa tristeza
era la última noche la noche de las
tristes despedidas y apenas y una
lágrima empañaba sus serenas pupilas
como el criado que deja al amo que le
hostiga arreglando su ático murmuraba
casi con la emoción de la alegría llorar
porque fortunas que podamos abandonar
nuestras humildes tierras
el duro pan que nos negó la patria por
más que los extraños nos maltraten no ha
de faltar nos en la patria ajena y los
hijos contentos se sonríen y la esposa
aunque triste se consuela con la firme
esperanza de que el que parte ha de
volver por ella pensar que han de partir
ese es el sueño que da fuerza en su
angustia a los que quedan
pues con este poema quería ilustrar el
tercer aspecto de mi trabajo sobre las
emociones yo las estudio en su contexto
histórico el sociocultural y en
situaciones específicas en las que la
interacción social da forma y transforma
las emociones de unos y de otros y eso
no se puede recrear en ningún
laboratorio
en cuanto al poder de la palabra quería
señalar que existe algo llamado
biblioterapia que por ejemplo en el
reino unido- hay gente que va a los
hospitales a leer poemas de shakespeare
a enfermos porque aunque no tengan la
capacidad de usar el lenguaje son
capaces de sentir el ritmo de las
palabras de la palabra poética la
palabra hablada y en eeuu por ejemplo
hay gente que se dedica a leer historias
de pérdida a niños que han perdido a sus
padres para que al compartir ese trauma
puedan procesar su tristeza y puedan
sentirse un poco menos solos
bueno pues terminó volviendo a la hora a
una situación específica de este momento
qué hacemos cuando escuchamos que la
frontera de estados unidos con méxico se
han estado separando a los niños
inmigrantes de sus padres y cómo
respondemos a leer informes sobre las
reacciones de tristeza miedo angustia e
ira de estos niños
y los problemas mentales que están
teniendo y al saber que entre mayo y
junio de 2018 se recetaron
fármacos de antidepresivos a 300 de
estos niños
y cómo nos sentimos al ver a esos otros
niños migrantes cruzar el mediterráneo
jugándose la vida con la esperanza de
mejorarla para terminar encontrándose
aquí con la soledad y el aislamiento
bueno pues quizás respondamos con
tristeza o con rabia o quizá esta
situación nos ayude a cultivar la
compasión la compasión no es una de esas
emociones que se sienten sin querer va
más allá de la empatía y de la
sensibilidad no consiste en imaginarse
la tristeza de otro y tenerle lástima
para que así ese otro se sienta menos
solo si sufrimos con él la compasión
se aprende se cultiva saliendo de la
misma miento no dejándonos cegar por
nuestras emociones o por las de otros y
utilizando la inteligencia para contener
los pensamientos negativos y dolorosos y
centrarnos en buscar soluciones
conjuntas gracias
[Aplausos]